what I want to do in this video is
reconcile the more traditional Drake
Equation with the stuff that we derived
or that we came up with we kind of
thought through it in the last several
videos so the more known Drake Equation
is this the number of detectable
civilizations in the galaxy is equal to
and they'll have this and this is not
the number of stars in the galaxy this
is the average rate of star formation
per year in the galaxy so star so let me
write this down
average rate of star formation which
seems kind of unintuitive and frankly it
is but hopefully will reconcile to show
you that this and what we're going to
show with the traditional Drake Equation
are actually the same thing so that's
the average rate of star formation so I
don't know what it is maybe it's ten
stars a year or something on that order
and then the rest of it looks pretty
similar so times the fraction of stars
that have planets so this product would
give you the average point that the
average stars with planet formations per
year you multiply that times the average
number of the average number of planets
capable of sustaining life for a star
that has planets for a solar system that
has planets so essentially if you
multiply this this is the average new
planets per year in our galaxy capable
of sustaining life you multiply that x
times this which is the same exact
fraction the fraction of those planets
that are capable of sustaining life that
are actually that this is capable of
sustaining life now we're saying that
the fraction that actually do develop
life and then of the life we care about
the fraction that actually does become
intelligent and of the fraction that
actually does become intelligent we care
about the fraction we care about the
fraction that eventually becomes
detectable that can actually communicate
and then in the traditional Drake
equation we multiply that times this L
over here times the detectable life of
the civilization so how long is that
civilization detectable are they
releasing radio waves or some
like it that a civilization like ours
can detect maybe there are other ways to
communicate and we're just not advanced
enough maybe in a few years we'll
discover in a few decades or a few
hundreds of years we'll discover that
all of the other advanced civilizations
are using a much more sophisticated way
of communicating that doesn't involve
electromagnetic waves who knows but this
is what we're thinking right now but
anyway the whole point here is to
reconcile this thing which is less
intuitive for me at least than with this
thing because I started up here with the
total number of stars in the galaxy the
traditional Drake Equation stars with
the starts with the average rate of star
formation so it's like well how does the
average rate of star formation gel with
the total number of stars or
civilizations that are now detectable
what I want to do is diagram that out a
little bit
and I'm gonna make a few assumptions I'm
gonna assume that this is kind of
constant that we're in a steady state so
this is constant and we are in a steady
state the reality is that what would
matter is the rate of star formation
maybe four or five six billion years ago
I don't know how long it has to be ago
so that now that it starts to become
realistic for real intelligence and real
detectable intelligence to exist but
let's just assume that this number is
constant for most of the life of the
galaxy obviously we're making all sorts
of crazy assumptions here so why not why
not make another one but what I want you
to show is that this is equivalent to
the number of stars in the galaxy
divided by the average life divided by
the average life of a star or the
average life of a solar system and if n
divided by this T sub s if that's the
same thing as our star then essentially
we have the same formulas and to see
that they're the same imagine this
imagine this that these that this year
so this is this year so this is 2,000
and well let me say this year this year
let's say that we have our star let's
say that this number is 10 we have 10
new stars in the galaxy so this is I'll
just say it's 10 so our star is equal to
10 so this height over here is 10 that's
what I'm depicting so if I were to slide
I could show this is 10 units high or
whatever and then last year there was
also
and so on and so forth now let's go to
let's go to whatever let's say that this
number this number right over here is 10
billion years the average star life is
10 billion years so let's go back 10
billion years into the past
so this so the average the average life
of a star is equal to 10 billion years
and we're assuming that this is constant
so 10 billion years ago this year they
were also they were also they were also
10 new stars came about and every year
in between every year in between you had
10 stars come about now how many total
stars would there be in our galaxy well
any star that came about so we could go
beyond that we could go 2 stars that
that were born more than 10 billion
years ago more than this T sub s years
ago so you could have a star that was
born that was born 10 billion in 1 years
ago on average we're talking about on
average here on average that star will
not exist anymore so that is not an odd
in existence the stars that are in
existence once again on average are the
ones that were born 10 billion years ago
all the way to the ones that were born
this year so you have 10 billion years
of star birth the ones that are still
around each year there's 10 of those
years so the total number of stars the
total number of stars should be equal to
the number of stars that are born each
year assuming that that is constant
times the average lifespan of the stars
x times the average lifespan of the
stars and if you look at it and once
again this is the that this works
because if the stars that were before
born before this lifespan don't exist
anymore they've died out on average we
care about kind of this area right over
here 10 stars per year times 10 billion
years and now if you manipulate this a
little bit you'll see that we'll get the
result we want let's solve for R so we
could just divide both sides by this T
so you get n star so the number of stars
in our galaxy now making a bunch of
assumptions divided by the
Everage life of the stars is equal to
the average is equal to the average
number of new stars per year is equal to
the average number of new stars per year
and we get our result if you replace
this if you replace this with this with
the total number of stars divided by T
total number of stars divided by T you
get the exact same result that we had
before you just change the order a bit
we can take this divided by T put it
under this n take it out of here and
then you get the exact same thing so
hopefully that reconciles it a little
bit for you